[Music]
good to see you
here i have no apologies that i'm aware
of
anybody got leaving early right
that's good um conflicts of interest
anybody
right we have the current register of
interests
that is in your agenda anybody got
anything to add to that
or is that okay
i will move that we receive that
register of interest can i have a
secondary please
i'll second it
thanks andrea
any discussion around that um
sorry madam chair how do i know um
when there's going to be a meeting for
all these people that i am
on the board with but i have no idea who
i have to contact
like you know for instance the um
uh where am i here all right
shift and domain advisory group i'm fine
with that
the township river and drain is
ratepayer i'm not sure who
who the contact person there is
can you find that out for me
i have given
your name to the contact person so they
should contact you now
when the next meeting is available
could you share with john what actually
happened or anything he needs
to be aware of
committees and there was also
um the sefton town as well
so i can send you the meet at the
minutes were taken by ecamm it's a nick
the recan
run meetings and responsibilities so
i'll send you them
thank you
you were in hospital i think at the time
john which is why you missed that
meeting
you were in hospital at the time and
that's why
we let um sandra deputise for you
right any other discussion around that
right all those in favor say those
against
carried right the confirmation of the
last minutes
anyone
i'm prepared to move those madam chair
john has seconded that any discussion
around the minutes
all those in favor say aye those against
carried right matters are rising
um from our last minutes we were going
to have a site visit to
to copper beach with the the roading
staff which had to get cancelled so k
is going to reorganize that one
so we'll get that out to everybody when
we know when there is
any other matters arising
right we have no deputations or
presentations
so our first report up is on the
speed limit review with bill
good to see you bill
so thank you this this report is uh
follow on from the consultation
that was done in september regarding
speed limits and
what we've called the tuahewe area but
is really the area between line side
road and
the ashley river we went out to
consultation
and the results are in the report
it was generally support
although not overwhelming support for
the changes we were proposing
we also had some feedback from nzta
which has resulted in some
changes from the the original proposal
so there
their concerns were around tolls road
they suggested that the safe and
appropriate speed on
tolls road was 60
kilometers now rather than the 80 that
we had proposed
we went back and had some discussion
with them they
they feel that the curves
and the the narrow nature of the road
make it inappropriate for an 80k speed
environment
our argument was that we didn't think
that there would be very good compliance
with the 60k environment
on on tolls road and so
the agreed position we've come to with
with the agency is that we will
reduce the speed or suggest reducing
speed limit to 80
and look at some improvements uh on the
geometry of tolls road to
include full consideration in the next
ltp
they're also concerned about our
proposals through tour huey
and following discussions with with ewe
we had come to the or recommended
reducing speed limit through to
kiwi village to 40 k's
now the agency was of the opinion that
that wasn't an appropriate speed fortui
and suggested leaving it at 50.
the police also agreed with with 50 as
an appropriate speed for
tuahiwi
in conjunction with that though
has put out for consultation discussion
a proposal to reduce
speeds around schools typically to 40
k's
anyway and so we've
left it at 50ks through tahiwi and we
will look at some further work that we
can do
through the village to reduce speeds
around the school
that may be that we look at some
variable speed limits
in the interim uh the agency has
indicated
that we can't change it to 40 yet
because the government hasn't actually
made that decision
so we can we can't change it to 40 as a
permanent speed limit yet
because the government hasn't hasn't
made that decision then they can only
work under the current rules
so we're suggesting leave it at at 50
and we will
look at some alternatives or some
options to to reduce it
near the school and as i said that will
either potentially either be
a a 40k temporary speed limit
at school start and finish times or
depending on
on how quickly the government moves to
change the rules we may look at a
permanent
full-time 40. the other area that the
agency expressed some concern around was
unsealed roads and we had consulted on
reducing the speed limit on all the
unsealed roads in that area from
100 to 80.
the agency has come back and said that
60 is a safe and appropriate speed for
unsealed roads
and that that is what they're pushing
towards
for unsealed roads throughout the
country
the operating speed on
all of those unsealed roads is around
the 60 to 65
and so we have agreed to or staff have
agreed with the agency to
to propose reducing all the unsealed
roads
in the area to 260.
and it'll be fair to say that as we look
at the remainder of unsealed roads in
the district
we're likely to also go down to 60
and one of the changes that the
government is proposing
for setting speed limits will be a a
regional
speed management process which is also
likely to
to result in all unsealed roads coming
down to 60.
so those those were the changes that
were made from from what we consulted on
there are also some questions about
pegasus boulevard and
certainly the consultation responses to
[Music]
to the change we were proposing in
pegasus boulevard from 17 to 60
was about 45 in favor which was
not quite a majority but there are uh
two or three other options so it was
the the most popular popular choice of
uh for that section now the agency is
also looking at the state highway
uh north of woody end and through the
pegasus roundabout and through to
waikoku village they have had some
some internal discussions about where
they end up on that
and that is at this stage quite unclear
certainly they're looking at reducing
the speed limit on on the highway but
what it reduces to
is is not yet certain
so happy to take questions
is
pushing off there it has been
um i can't understand why you can't keep
going past the school into a healing
that it can't be dropped down to 40.
that means to most schools
on the state highway you um drop down to
40.
um just seems
very much safety you know
and i'm sure even if the nzta
don't recommend it i don't see why the
local council can't sort of
put the aura in and say if for safety
reasons it should be forty
the cro in front of the mirai and the
school
thank you
so i guess that yeah what we're looking
at for the school in particular
is either a
a temporary spirit or variable speed
limit which means that at school
start and finish times and and other
times when there's a lot of activity
there
we can reduce it to 40 and and we need
to work with the school in particular to
to set that up or if it looks like there
will be a move to a general
40 outside schools we we might move to
to do that instead so there's a couple
options we're looking at
to to reduce it outside the school
thank you madam chair um first
question to you thank you is fortuah i
believe there is some
portable mobile um electronic signage
that is available within the community
within waimak
is it has ever been used near to here
near the school just to have some visual
for those that are approaching as far as
what speed they are
doing
so we have five of those devices in the
district
um which we rotate around around various
sites and we're
we're in the process of setting up a
site and to here we to
locate them into
thank you um and question number two is
regards to pegasus wood end talking
about state highway one
just for accountability and it's not you
that i'm questioning here
but do we have a time frame
now
um they're they're working on it uh
and they've had some stuff changes and
the person that was working on it has
now
moved on and so that's been handed over
to somebody else and
it's the same old story
sorry bill but thank you i did get my
violin out there thank you
well um in the nzta memo that came back
to it talks about
um the saas
what does that stand for
so it's safe and appropriate speed
um yeah there was
um i did have another question where is
it
so the pegasus boulevard i mean it was
very equal
the um
the percentage support between um
sort of retaining at 70
which was 42 and 45
for reducing to 60
[Music]
so yeah it's
yeah any
i mean from my reading of it nz ta looks
like they actually wanted it even lower
in terms of that they regarded it as
safe operating speed
my question is is i i can't really see
why
in terms of there is
no houses directly on the boulevard
there are a few side roads there's a
roundabout
there are there are no pedestrians
crossing
the boulevard because there are
underpasses the cyclists tend to use the
path
up the side and
so to me yeah it just seems odd and i
just
wonder um how that relates to when you
look at the state highway where you have
nzta
saying a safe speed from wood in to
north of the pegasus roundabout is 70
kilometers an hour
and yet they are saying a safe speed on
pegasus boulevard
is is 60 or or is it 15 you know
i mean it sounds like they would
actually prefer 50. um
but yeah
it would be fair to say that with
respect to the the state highway
the agency isn't speaking with one voice
and so there are some differences of
opinion within the agency about what the
appropriate speed is
on the highway i think that
there is certainly a desire to reduce it
particularly that would end through to
the roundabout and my feeling is that
we'll probably
go to 60 but that hasn't been confirmed
the other the other factor in there is
that the agency
has stipulated that we're not allowed to
have any new 70
speed limits and there is a
desire to do away with the existing 70s
so there was a desire as we did this
this wider review to look at the 70s
and look at what we were changing to and
certainly pushing it up to 80
was probably not a definite no-go
and reducing it to 60 was the
alternative
so yeah so whilst the agency is
suggesting that we
do away with the 70s there is no rule
requiring that
at the moment but at some stage i
suspect that we may have to face it
can i just have an extra question there
in terms of
the the changes in speed limits like at
the moment it's 70ks out on the state
highway they're not
the proposal was it would drop 60 down
the boulevard
and then 50 when you enter pegasus
itself
i mean is that too many speed limits
would it be better to actually just keep
pegasus boulevard as it is
until we know what nzta are actually
doing out on state highway 1
on that section so at the moment it
would then retain it at 70
until we actually know what nzta are
going to do with their speed limits
it might actually encourage them to move
a bit faster
um i think that there is a good argument
for
for taking that that stand as well um
and i think that it does make some sense
thank you madam chair um just a further
question on from
shona was was it questioned why they
want to remove 70
uh i think that
my interpretation rather than than
anything i've actually heard from them
is that they were looking to rationalize
speed limits generally
and certainly we in the past had
50 70 and 100
with sun 90s
they have wanted in the urban areas to
to reduce
to have some 40s and 50s and 60s
and there was a feeling that if we had
40s 50s 60s 70s 80s
90s 100s and 110s
it was just too many different speed
limits so there was a desire to
to remove the 70s and the 90s
to sort of try and provide
a a degree of consistency i guess across
the country and
a degree of consistency with within an
area with different speed limits
so i think that's my interpretation of
where they're coming from but i
certainly not necessarily any official
word from
thank you
i'm so i'm probably flying on from
andrea but why can't we ask them for a
time frame before when they're going to
change the
on state highway one because i think
that we should
what we've waited for so long for it and
but i think and using staff changes to
me is no excuse at all
thank you
we can certainly we can certainly ask
for that
i that doesn't necessarily give us a
guarantee that we'll get a satisfactory
answer but we can ask
thank you madam chair uh bill if we
wanted something different to what's
been agreed
in the report with ncta i see you've
gone back to them with various
suggestions
uh what are the implications if we want
something different because there was a
section in that report
that said if we wanted something
different we should really
look at uh getting legal advice which uh
seemed to a little bit of a sort of
steer that we weren't really to uh
disagree
there are there are a number of clauses
in the speed limit setting rule
that that they have quoted and have then
said that if we don't meet those clauses
we we need to be getting legal advice
now some of them are open to a little
bit of interpretation
um but certainly
the interpretation from from the agency
is has been very fairly clear on
on some of those
now whether we agree with it we can
certainly go back and
and argue but i think we need to be
careful
in terms of doing something different to
to what we've agreed with them
one at a time um i don't have a strong
view on pegasus boulevard um
i'm aware that ncta are not keen on 70
speed limits um if the board itself
wanted to leave it at 70
until the main north road speed limit
was finalized
would that be an issue
i think because of the uncertainty about
the main north road limit i think we
could make a
reasonable argument that that is a
good course of action
any other questions
john i'd just like to make a statement
you know could put people talking to the
microphone rather than
being way back here because i can hardly
hear
some of this conversation
thank you
right any other questions
mark so can any other roads be added or
is this it
probably not at the at the moment
unless there is some specific reason i
guess that we've
consulted on on these roads
um so i mean potentially if there is one
that is
that we've missed out that should have
been included
and there's obviously appropriate then
then we would then we could include that
but i think that
as a general rule we we've consulted on
these we've talked to ncta about them
um so i think that probably
that that's where we're at
it was just um gladstone road which i
think i've raised before work
uh at two roads it doesn't the zoning
should change there to get
i think it's uh 80 but it goes halfway
through the residential air with a new
residential area so i think that should
be added if it could be
we have programmed later on the year a
review
of the speed limits in the the periphery
of all of the urban areas in the
district
so so where we change from 50 to 80 or
50 to 100
around the the outsides of all the urban
areas so
so we would include gladstone at that at
that point at that stage
so you're saying it can't be added to
this thing
i don't think so
maybe sorry i haven't turned it off but
um can you check it out if it could be
i think it would be quite difficult
considering it hasn't been consulted on
and um yeah i mean adding it in to the
round later this year
maybe what has to be done but please
check it out though that would be
that would be much appreciated um
i would actually like to to move an
emotion remove the motion
um but i would like to amend it to
actually say that to retain pegasus
boulevard
at 70 until we know
what is happening out on state highway 1
uh
north of of wood end
would i have a seconder for that please
take your pick
[Laughter]
i'll second it
just to speak to that i think you know
the gravel roads um
the unsealed roads around our area you
know i think for the most part 60k
it is a fair speed for those roads
um there are a few people who would like
to go faster
um but often they will come up behind
someone who doesn't want to go that fast
so yeah so i think that is fair um my
reasoning behind the pegasus boulevard
is i'm not saying that it should stay at
70 forever
but i think those speed limit changes
need to be
managed as much as as possible um
so you know i think that would be good i
found it
slightly ironic in the um email from
nzta that
they said that they
expected all road controlling
authorities um
to to move as quickly as possible
and that was a requirement of the
current
government policy statement when nzta
have been quite tardy
in their own efforts um when we were
promised
speed reductions would be in place by
christmas
they didn't say which christmas um we
did take it to mean chris
christmas 2019. uh so yeah i do find
that
that quite ironic because i found it
quite strange that
nzta didn't actually seem to know what
speed limits changes had been done in
recent times that they had no
record of the changes that happened last
year
on rengar wood end road grissoms road
north brook road and those ones but um
yeah so i'll i will get off my um
my bandwagon around speed limits and ask
if andrea has anything to
add a new job
i just want to thank you madam chair and
say thank you bill to you enjoying the
team because it is a big body of work so
don't take that for granted and we
probably do use you as a vehicle
to release their frustration no pun
intended with the vehicle
um but i mean it's very very much
underlying um
thing that we're quite passionate about
is about the road safety then you can
see that
from the questions we're asking you
about that there so i do thank you but
it won't go away we still will be the
squeaky wheel
to see something happen we won't go away
so thank you for being our advocate
i was just going to ask you a question
about pataki road
and um to a fair road
um they to me are very narrow roads
and 80 was even 80s um
quite fast going down there with a car
coming the opposite
direction there's very little leeway
going past i wonder whether they
shouldn't be
at a lower speed not
i know i i can tell you some of the
people down there
um they get a bit scared of coming out
their driveways
they've told me that okay thank you
i think that we're trying to to
and and the agency as well is trying to
have a consistent speed limit
for sealed roads generally
um so i think that they have
an approach of going for 100 for very
high quality
and then 80 for for lesser quality
sealed roads
in rural areas and so i think that
it would be a struggle to to get um
you know anything other than than 80
unless there was a significant crash
history there
well it just concerns me that there's a
very narrow
um carriageway um
so you get two vehicle vehicles going
80k
and coming up there's very little leeway
because it's very narrow
the carriageway is quite narrow
thank you
uh i'll move it closer to me uh
john i
think we're all road engineers when it
comes to discussing road safety and
speed limits
which doesn't make the professionals job
any easier
i think the nzta report was actually
one of the better ones i've read i
didn't actually
disagree with hardly anything that was
in it
um at the end of the day safety is
paramount
um this report i i think is a good one
which i'm happy to support
with the minor tweak to pegasus
boulevard which i wondered about when i
read the report and i don't really have
a firm view but it would be good to have
the same
speed limit as you suggest linking up
with the main north
state highway 1. so i'm i'm more than
happy to support
the proposal i'm not sure how this is
going to be implemented because i assume
this report is going to all the other
boards
and it'll be interesting to see how bill
manages to bring that all together
so uh good luck but i am supportive of
your motion madam chair
any other anything else from anybody
else
um yeah i would actually also like to
say thank you bill for the report it is
a very good report and please don't take
it personally
because i mean as andrea says we we you
know
we do take the safety seriously and we
have been on this
journey for some time now um but yeah we
certainly do value
what the roading team actually does and
the fact that you are
slightly meat in the sandwich as it were
at times
so yes please do not take it personally
but there's a very good
um there are consultation as usual bill
so
thank you so i would like to put that
motion
all those in favor say aye those against
carried and say thank you very much bill
for the for the report and yes good luck
going to the the other community boards
and trying to
meld it into into one thing thanks bill
ryan now we're going to talk about the
car park on territory moana drive so
i'll let
ryan talk us through that one
thank you madam chair um good evening
this report
seeks approval from the board on the
design and implementation of the
proposed car park
along territory moana drive so this car
park
followed a submission from the board as
part of the 2019 2020 annual plan
um following the upgrade of the tutopatu
trail between pegasus and waikiki beach
has seen a lot of increased use
and with no formal parking available at
their entrance it's lead to a number of
users parking on the grass verge
a 35 000 budget was allocated with an
annual plan to implement a gravel car
park along territory marijuana drive
so staff have discussed the provision of
this car park with the trust around the
proposed location on the corner
and the trust have confirmed that they
are happy for council to proceed in this
location
the initial grebel car park design was
considered by the board and i'd just
like to thank the board for their
feedback during the lockdown
i know it wasn't a formal process so it
was appreciated um
there was a lot of discussion around the
possibility of a fully sealed surface
however based on the budget available it
would be a very small car park
if that option was chosen so following
that feedback
staff have updated the design to include
two accessible car parks two feet into
the accessible trail
and depending on the prices received we
can easily extend the
design of the car carpet to include
additional car parks so
happy to take any questions on that
any questions from anybody
[Music]
hello uh thanks ryan it was good to um
have your comments while we're all the
lockdown
sort of solving problems um
do we have any idea from
the contractors who you may have
approached what the
cost of this particular plan is
at one point if there was any sort of
leftover we could extend it
but any update on costings
uh so if this is approved by the board
we'll look at going out for pricing
this week based on engineer's estimate
which is using
rates from recent contracts i think this
comes in just under the
budget available but again depending on
what the rates are at the moment there
may be some
additional money available when those
prices come back in
so would be hoped they would be able to
get some additional car parks in if
possible
uh to confirm ryan i saw those four diff
it was four different businesses that
you were going to approach for prices
has it gone out to tinder or you've
actually just approached four local
businesses
and also like to acknowledge we did
request if you could try and use local
if you could so thank you for that
um but has it been a tender or you've
just gone directly to those
companies uh so it's not a
formal tender process based on the
procurement policy
formal formal team that would be over a
hundred thousand but we've approached
the
essentially five companies for local
businesses to get those prices
you
thank you minimum share the um other
and for good work here ryan uh with if
there was um
two questions which is one do
you do is the review in terms of the
number of car parks that's likely to be
required
and um part then the second question
comes is
if it does come in under budget
i believe we should ticket at the moment
we should be considering just um coming
in
under budget appreciating that and
putting the money to to one side rather
than looking to
increase the size of the car park
particularly if
the number of car parks is going to be
okay for the next few years for the
number of cars that are likely to use it
cheers uh so we haven't done a formal
study or anything of the number of cars
using that area um the design of the car
park was
identified was designed to take
advantage of their budget available
any other questions
now would somebody like to put a motion
for me
[Music]
so i propose we move number two a
b and c that will receive the report and
prove
this the design and the staff are meant
to be implementing the proposed car park
design
thank you
thanks philip for seconding that
just acknowledging what phillip said
through lockdown it was informal use
with zoom but it was very productive
and thank you for answering her
questions and that and i think it's a
fantastic result
so thank you for your hard work
uh thank you madam chair
i think it is a good outcome that was
sort of a one win-win all round for the
disabled parking
and getting a reasonable number of car
parks but unlike
board member thompson i would like to
see the the budget used on car parks
and if we can squeak an extra couple of
gravel car parks and i think now is the
time to do it
so i'm very pleased to second your
motion board member
alan
you know i'd just like to say um yeah
i'm
in support of um if there could be more
car parks that would be fine
um my understanding is that in the
future if
we do need more car parking there
then that can be looked at at that time
with if if the budget allows
um because hopefully you know in the
future it will become
a very in-demand car park and um you
know the area along there is
the um as the natives grow that the
trust is planting and things like that
it should be quite an exciting place so
from a safety point of view again we're
looking at safety tonight
seems to be the the course of the
evening is it having this off-road car
park will make it so much safer
for people um i've seen people parking
over the
current walking path they reverse out
into the traffic
you know it's it has just been a bit
diabolical so
you know i look forward to seeing this
car park done
anybody got anything else i'd like to
add
um i looked at if the budget actually
did
allow or sometime in the future is going
to be very easy to add to this car park
so i think if if it's required
and you can build this car park as it's
designed
at the moment it's very easy to tag on
another
section sometime in the future
so for the sake of making sure you get
the car parks
i'd say go for what's there thank you
anything else from anybody
andrew yeah just um
not quite sure procedurally but my two
comments which is one is um based on my
personal observations that's
um a total degree in terms of it's great
to see the car park i mean it's a much
much improved over what's there from a
number of perspectives probably
encourage more use
and certainly from a safety and other
perspectives
um and it's the car parks my personal
observation would be there's plenty
there given the number of people that
tend to
park there so i i do would like to and
to amend
the recommendation to include a specific
requirement that
if the tender for as for the car parts
of scoped
comes in under budget we run with the
scope of the work as required
and i just don't quite know how
procedurally to include that but i'd
like to
i think it is moving in motion to do
that
so you're putting that motion as an
amendment
do we have a seconder for that
john right we will move to that
substantive motion then
andrew would you like to speak to that
motion
uh i don't really have anything more to
add i just think that we um
i think the car parks ample for the next
few years for what's there based on
personal observation and we should be
conscious of people's money
and um therefore you know certain times
it's great to get a bit more but
it's just about it's just a car park it
can be extended quite simply anytime so
let's see a bit of social conscious and
and um prudence and um and
you know run with it as it is and
whatever thought in today's environment
we will get a very good price
and we could save the council and the
taxpayer and the ratepayers some money
john
[Music]
are you still looking at local
contractors
for this ride so people north of the
waimea area
okay
did you want to speak to the motion john
anybody else like to speak to that
motion
um i suppose
you know one of the questions i would
have would be
is that it's more cost effective to do
as much as possible
now when the machinery is there um i
mean if we did manage to squeeze in
it would only probably be another couple
of car parks it's not going to be a
major
thing so i would think when the
machinery is there is actually the
better time
to do that so i will
be voting against the motion
anybody else
right i will put the motion that um the
car park
the design goes ahead and that it is
limited
to the number of car parks in the
proposal
so all those in favor say aye
those against no
that motion is lost does anybody want
their vote against recorded
recorded as being specific to you that
you voted against it
and i have my vote recorded too thanks
courtney
um so having lost that motion we moved
back to the original motion which was
um the one that andrea put i think was
you andrea was it
to move to a c madam chair
all right we had a seconder for that any
further discussion around that one
right i'll put that to the vote then all
those in favor of
the motion as it's stated in the agenda
say i
those against carried
i'd like to say thank you very much ryan
for that report it was a pleasure
working with you via zoom it's actually
good to meet you rather than
doing it online so thank you very much
for the work that you did
no it was more difficult during lockdown
so we certainly do appreciate the work
that's been done and that you've been
able to keep the project actually moving
along
so thank you very much for that
right our next next one is uh the
ratification of the board submission to
the
waimakariri district council's draft
annual plan
which feels like a long time ago i do
say so
but we've all seen it and um it's been
it's gone it's been
submitted on the hearings have been held
and deliberations have been held
so um
personally i'd like to just move that we
received the report and
retrospectively ratify the submission
sorry
do i have a seconder for that
mark
i've got nothing to say other than yes
it's been it's gone it's done
anything anybody else would like to add
but i'll put that motion to the vote all
those in favor say aye
those against and that one is carried
the next one is the ratification of our
submission to the environment canterbury
draft
annual plan which again has
been and gone and happened
could somebody move a motion for me
please
thank you phillip
we'll let andrew second that one phillip
i know just just to add madam chair i
thought you
prepared a very very comprehensive and
very good
submission um it'll be interesting to
see what happens
um i think things will change
but to what degree i haven't caught up
with yet so i
i think it was a very good submission it
was done sort of during lockdown
down from memory so um this lockdown
actually has a lot going for it really
the car park and submissions
so more more than happy to uh support
the recommendation
yeah just concur i don't think i've
really got anything additional to add
but a good submission
nice mix of um of some facts and there's
some
chunky sort of um facts and
well presented so pleased to um
seeking that recommendation
any other discussion right i'll put that
motion all those in favor say aye
those against is carried
the next one up is correspondence and
again this seems so long ago
and this is uh receiving the the uh
the letter that we wrote to the minister
of transport the honourable
honourable phil twyford that the mayor
kindly hand delivered and
passed over and the other one is
the letter to jim harland of the new
zealand transport agency
regarding the woody safety improvements
do i have someone would like to move
that those be
received
i'll move them energy that they received
a second up
thanks mark andrea
i think you say madame cheer thank you
no i'm not gonna when do we get a
response
if it was written in march
the 60 million dollar question
i don't know and we did actually ask
mr harland some some questions in our
letter
which was around some updated
traffic count figures would be
appreciated if they would be provided to
the board
the last i read online is when they
announced the
um signalized crossings
at the woody school was that yes they
were working on it and
it would be an in due course we would we
would hear more
so i suppose i'm only sickening that
these leaders are that we're proving
these letters but i think that we should
send a follow-up letters to both them
and ask them for responses
uh thank you uh look i just wanted to
briefly
note and compliment both um
mr mayor and the board for your advocacy
i i frankly don't think there's anything
more that you can do
both in relation to the safety
improvements issue
and in relation to acceleration of the
wooden bypass
i probably advise i don't think there is
net benefit and a follow-up letter at
this point i think what's going on
is this combination of consideration of
the shovel ready projects and as you
know the bypass is
one of those and and then uh
if or if if it isn't on that list and to
be accelerated to be
advanced to the next step then what is
the response around safety improvements
in the interim
and what's the timing of those um
the wheels in wellington grind in their
own particular way
and time frame and i appreciate that's
really frustrating
uh i know that bill and joanne
work really do work genuinely hard
to keep the liaison going at a a lot
better regional level
but ultimately given the scale of the
investment both in safety improvements
and in the bypass that
this is relying on national pro programs
for all i know the next round of shovel
ready projects
decision making went to the minute went
to the cabinet today
um if it wasn't this monday then it
could well be next monday
so my advice to you is uh
let's let's get the decision making
around shovel ready projects
does the bypass advance to the next step
again
or not and then and then to consider
what might be the action course of
action from there
uh just a few comments
i mean i disagree that we don't ask
again especially to jim harland
i mean we've had asked what date was it
the 8th of march
um and and i'm talking about the safety
improvements i'm not talking about the
bypass we know the bypass will be some
time off but
we're asking for a sign to be shifted
150 metres
so i think we should ask again and i
think we should be doing it from
that's not only this avenue every avenue
that we possibly can
thank you i agree
and i'm a support too i don't think we
should be quieting down
i think we should be revving it up
i totally agree with that
let's not give up we've been fighting
for it for a long time
um councillors how would you feel about
if we we wrote to
um mr harland well madam chair i was
just going to ask i'm not sure of
meeting procedure if we could ask the
mayor if he has had any
feedback from this correspondence
perhaps before we
take the matter further
thank you madam chair and and members of
the board just to say that
yes i did have a response back from the
minister
um which was similar to what we've had
in the past
but we did um decided through nzta to
advance it through the shovel ready
which is the program that we've advanced
that matter through
the minister gave me an indication when
he was in the office that he would re
certainly when we met with him in person
that he would consider it further
and take some further advice from his
officials he took on board the comments
certainly from the local community and
the schools the school that
um included their correspondence also
but i got a very good hearing in there
and following that nzta did make an
announcement around safety improvements
at the school of signalized crossing
there
i'm in the process of actually writing
to nzta myself i had a meeting with
school students the other day by zoom at
williams school
and i have indication to them that i
would write to
nzta to find out the timing of when that
crossing is going to be implemented as
well as the other safety improvements
that are implemented so
i'm going to be writing myself i'm happy
to copy the border and if the board
wishes to send a letter of support with
that
i'm happy for that to go as well but i'm
in the process of doing that right now
terms of the minister no harm i'm
putting another letter
to the minister but at the present time
it's been considered in the shovel
reading we don't have an answer on that
yet
and perhaps i think mr markham's advice
is sound that we should
just to wait to hear where it gets to
and the shovel ready process first
then then we can make a decision as to
how we'll further
ways of advancing that but in terms of
the safety improvements
i think we should keep the pressure on
that because the nzta have made
commitments in that area
and i'd like to know myself when they're
going to implement those
in the timing so i'm happy to send you a
copy of the letter i'm
going to put out this week
yeah thanks for that mr mayor i think
you know in general we were talking
about
the safety improvements and that you're
happy to leave that the
um the wooden bypass to the side at the
moment as it is in that
pile with the shovel ready projects but
i think the safety improvements
are one that we probably would like to
follow up councillor stuart
anything you'd like to add or
okay i'll draft a letter up and send it
around to everybody and
the mayor will email his letter through
to us so we can
actually see what's being said um really
good to hear
uh mr mayor that you you know have
committed with the school students to
following up
you know on their behalf they have been
doing this for for so many years
they you know it's been quite a project
for them i think some of them have
actually moved through the school
with the the project on the safety
improvements so
it's um yeah it'll be an interesting day
when the safety improvements all happen
and the
school can rest on its laurels
so thank you very much for that
thank you madam chair um could the board
letter
be sent with the mayor's letter so they
both go at the same time
and maybe it could even say we support
his letter
if you say his before you've written
yours but two letters are better than
one
thank you
yeah that's a good idea rex for me
i think we should leave a motion that we
will receive the
correspondence
um and yeah we will draft a letter to go
with the mayors to nzta around the
safety improvements
so i will move that do i have a seconder
for that
john thank you i've got nothing further
to add than what i've already added
so
anything else anybody would like to add
try to put that motion all those in
favor say aye
those against that's carried
cheers report i did a very brief cheers
report because i
really couldn't be uh yeah i thought of
going back through my diary to see what
i'd been doing
um all through march and
i did actually do it but i never wrote
the report on it and it was
um it seems quite some time ago
so um yeah i just did a summary of sort
of really what's been happening
well we've been in um in lockdown
and i mean i'd have to say it was really
good that we could actually carry on
some of the work with you know with ryan
doing the work on the car park
you know we got submissions done you
know i presented at hearings
um yeah we sort of you know there was
quite a bit of work going on
residents were still contacting us with
issues and we were following up on those
so you know things happened and
um i could say it was it was it was a
it was a nice break not to have to go
out to too many meetings
i would have to say and to actually be
able to wear my ugg boots when i had a
zoom meeting so
um i will leave it at that but i will
put the motion that my report be
received do i have a seconder for that
i'll second it madam chair thank you
thanks andrea i have nothing further to
add any other discussion around that
but i'll put the motion all those in
favor say aye
those against is carried
matters for information just the
community board meetings from back in
march
from the other three community boards
any discussion around those any
questions
right can i have somebody move that we
receive those
i'll move we receive them andrea
thanks phillip
any discussion anything right i will
put that motion all those in favor say
aye
those against and that one's carried
anybody like anything they would like to
add in the members information exchange
probably like you madam chair i found
that
i've i found it was quite productive
actually
um with um with lockdown to be fair is
as a board it was quite effective and
one thing i took out of
a lot of zoom meetings everyone had is
you can see a lot more passion
in those that are actually presenting in
a zoom meeting more than sitting around
a room
and i mean that you know comically and
also passionately with people's
i don't know um viewpoints
that come across um for me um it was
still busy like with zoom meetings um
i also was co-authored to local welfare
committee which was
which complemented obviously the waimak
advisory group
health advisory group which was good and
obviously the big thing was
about care an affian help
to our local community and of course the
biggest thing was food was the major
thing
and um one thing just personally
that's come out of it is that i feel
so proud to be part of our district and
this afternoon when i was on my bike
coming down would end i actually had a
little bit of a melancholy moment
i know that sounds a bit funny but i
passed about six people
and there was all acknowledgings and
smiles and hellos and i don't know if we
could get that
in another district if i was in the city
so i feel very fortunate to be a member
of the community but also to be part of
this board
so there you go
thanks for that andrea anybody got
anything else they would like to add
there are some nice people in the world
andrea
i think the other thing to recognize and
i send an email to this effect during
the lockdown is that
we're lucky to have some of the
facilities that uh council
and where the community board their own
we way have supported so like some of
those
walking biking tracks and other bits and
pieces you know it's it's um
and you think at the time there was a
bit of flack over some of those things
like one of those big bike paths and
whatnot but
but i think it came into its they came
into their own
and were um so widely used
and i just got my fingers crossed that
that um
enthusiasm and useful will continue and
it does seem to me initially
cheers
right anything else from anybody hello
uh thank you thank you madam chair i
thought i'd give you just a brief update
of what uh some councillors have been
doing
uh we haven't been on holiday during
lockdown
um you will have
well you submitted on the annual plan
deliberation so
um that that took a couple of days
and the decisions are going to the
council
on the 16th of june um you may have read
that the council is coming up with a
recovery plan
uh he did better than before
and i think simon to my left has
something to do with that
so thank you for that work simon i
attended a free
local government new zealand webinar and
the word was free
on how we could look after
the economic effects of covert 19
in terms of rates and i'm pleased to say
that having sat through the seminar
um as a council we'd already discussed
all the options that were presented in
the seminar
so we're right up with the play i think
in that respect
um the other thing that um i've been
doing i've become the chair of the
waimakariri district
creative new zealand communities
which i must admit i didn't know
we had that committee initially it
effectively
um assesses applicants from artists of
all types
and makes grants twice twice a year
i must be talking too close to it john
so we we do operate the creative
communities
scheme so if you know of artists and
it's not just
painting it's art and it's very broader
sense
including ice sculpturing and things
like that
at expose twice a
twice a year we do assess these
applications
and make grants i think in the last
round we had 14
um applicants and we had sufficient
funds to satisfy
all of them if we thought they were
worthy of support
um my portfolio is regulation and civil
defense
um and that's that's been quite a busy
area with civil defence during covet 19.
um the emergency operation centre was
established
tessa sturley comes across as a welfare
officer and there was assistance given
to
food being supermarkets and those sorts
of things
the regulatory people checked camping
grounds freedom camping
and kept an eye on things the
planning unit has two significant things
at the moment coming up
one is line lime living in silver stream
which is quite an exciting retirement
complex
that will probably be going to a hearing
shortly
um the other thing that's happening out
here is the rangiora race course
um looking at a quarry in the middle of
the
racetrack so i'm not
sure where that's heading but it
probably will lead to a hearing i
suspect
um the environmental services unit that
looks after animal control
alcohol licensing food premises
and health including toxic algal blooms
in lake pegasus the
the building unit has seen a drop in new
consent
not a huge drop as far as i'm aware
and dealing with tiny house issues
at the moment seem to be wearing
their head again
the other thing that i've had some
meetings with and you'll be familiar
with it it's in our area
the sefton community hall um
applied to the annual plan process
about whether they rebuild uh relocate
um and i've been working with the
sefton library um regarding its disposal
it's quite an interesting and
tricky little problem but uh hopefully
we'll get somewhere because the
intention is that money from that will
go towards the um
either repairs or new community hall for
sefton
so all these things have been happening
during lockdown so um it's been quite a
busy period
thank you
yes i do have a bit that i could update
you on um
my chair ordered and risk and that came
instead of having a separate meeting
came to the full council last week
one of the um things that i think's
particularly
um interesting uh will be that
we've put money for the um uh post
covered recovery plan
but we've also acquired a market view
um program which um
which gives the council
[Music]
an indication of of um
spend through um
retail outlets and also hopefully number
of jobs
that are within the district so we got
hold of that
pre-covered um and we will benchmark
where we were hopefully before before
covert and
have reports simon will be furnishing um
i think the first report in august which
will give us an understanding of what we
where we really are as far as jobs and
spend
goes um and i'm hopeful that as a result
of that
and and with the we've put a half a
million
towards the recovery plan that we will
be able to
the word is nimble we will be nimble
and be able to respond where there are
particular
needs identified um through this
and that's working in conjunction with
our
local economic development arm which is
enc
of course so we've just ticked off their
um well their statement of intent which
i would like to see
incorporates um recovery plan
milestones and outcomes uh through
getting this market view data
so that's that's a new one for us and
it would enable us to sort of feel the
pulse of what is happening
out in the community and hopefully
respond quickly where we see
needs so that's that's quite exciting as
far as i'm concerned also
just on the um environmental front um
as you'll be aware mps fresh water
um we got some our heads up a couple of
weeks week or so ago from the government
about where
where it's heading um pc7
hasn't had a date yet to be heard
and i just heard today because i've just
come from a water zone
that in fact um ecan is
or not waiting to hear um
uh the well when it's gazetted
which the government is indicating will
be quite
soon um and you can take from that it'll
be considered
before the election uh the um
pc seven and the various hearings um and
plan changes will have to
give effect to that uh so they're
they're not waiting but they're
expecting that they all have to respond
to that and in that and what comes out
of the
the hearings and the other thing that is
quite significant is
ecan was asked by the government to
coordinate
um a bid for money
post covered for environmental projects
and here uh within well it was a
regional
uh council initiative um requests
throughout the country so ecan has
been buzzing around putting together
everything you'd ever want
and we asked we are in here with quite
um sizable um environmental
programs excuse me which is still
all live and today um
andrew art said he expects to hear
within a fortnight where we
are and the the bid through econ is
creation of
186 jobs and i didn't actually note and
i can't get into my
um he gave a presentation which i even
got a copy of so and i didn't take
um apart from the jobs but it's um it's
over a hundred million i think number
pride for
for um um for canterbury
and a hunk of it is is here um
project that i've been promoting and
champion
and is is particularly the type of thing
that is
looks like favored and these are
i mean essentially they're planting
programs um
rehabilitation programs that are
rather than um
[Music]
shovel ready these these are
what i'm trying to say is these are
people intensive ones so the
the groups of people going out doing
planting and environment type projects
so for those of you who've been around a
bit um this is sort of going back to the
task force green type of thing and the
nature of the programs that ecan has put
forward create
[Music]
create a number of like as i said almost
jobs throughout the region uh over a
period of
five years and he's expecting
that we'll be starting in july so as
soon as within two weeks they're going
to hear what's what's
um got the tick and they're expected to
bang in really quickly these milestones
they have to
adhere to end so it's going to be um
what do we
call it i i don't think that ecan is
used to working this way so it's going
to challenge them all
and um andrew arps acknowledged that
so um for for here particularly here
um the taranaki stream may get a bit of
a boost
uh with extra funding and certainly
um there's a fund that uh sophie allen
has
applied to fish passage fish
enhancement stuff and again
a planting around the floodgate
enhancing inanga
environment so that's gone in as as well
that's that's a separate that's an ecan
fund
but certainly there's the opportunity
and we think
we'll will get something that um
boots all um the sorts of planting that
you've been doing
progressively and in relatively small
bits
could really get a kick up the bum with
it all
um so be prepared
and all good news yeah
question with that just i mean are there
actually the plants
out there to do this planting again
that's that's going to be a bit of a
challenge because everybody in the whole
country is um and the answer is probably
no
um part of the program is i think ecan
is
um and even here within waimakariri uh
looking at growing on and creating um
a nursery i think that's a nikken rather
than here but certainly
within green space they've talked about
having um growing on
that growing on trees so that you will
have a
a nursery or a source of trees
yeah so it's um it yes
that
you know if in fact you get the go-ahead
within say a year or so because it's a
five-year program
you will have building up um
planning still
well thanks for that anybody got
anything else to add
i move on to consultation projects and
we haven't got any
[Music]
so that's good
the board funding update we've got zero
dollars on our discretionary grant
because we've been very good this year
and
given the money away to community groups
and the general landscaping fund which
we will carry through to next year is
sitting at twelve thousand four hundred
and thirty dollars
um media items um
i worked with uh comms during lockdown
on the story around the
pegasus pegasus beach access that was
done
and that got some some pretty good
traction out there the
waimakariri access group was extremely
happy that they got mentioned and they
got a lot of traffic onto
their facebook page so they were very
happy with that one
anything anybody would like me to cover
in
this month's
thing that i put out
it's probably a question and actually
the mirror is gone now but it's just
actually
in regards to the templeton group and
we've all seen that the commercials up
for sale and pegasus at the moment
and we know that they arden they want to
get in and get out
that's the method of rondo but
my question is the waterfall's going
which is great that's fantastic has
there been any more communication about
the lake
um i have been in contact with
the templeton group uh and
working work in progress um
we're still showing as a toxic algal
bloom at the moment i think we need
one more clear test before that comes
out of the lake
um but yes it is actually certainly
on my my list of things what i mean form
of
the community it's always so topical
that subject is that are we remiss
that we're obviously doing work behind
the scenes but maybe need to update
um i welcome people's thoughts maybe
it's better not to say anything
say nothing or as you know people assume
we don't not care shouldn't say that but
are not actively
trying to solve the problem i don't know
what your thoughts are
john i speak about um i think one of the
biggest problems with pegasus lake and
it's different to our lakes
is there's no aquatic planting around
the edges
to actually clean the water and to move
it um
and it's contrary i know to the everyone
wants a view
but there's not enough shade over the
lake to
like our lake is in a very similar
situation
and we have willows hanging over the
lake
creating um shade in there and plus
we're getting flexes and that's starting
to pop up
so um i think that's one of the
reasons why pegasus lake has never
going to clean completely unless there's
some biological
steps made towards sort of
building around the periphery thank you
yeah i mean i i certainly have been
working in the in the background around
the lake um certainly the mayor has
shown
his support for that um he has met with
templeton group
um we also met with the manager of
utilities
around that lake so yeah whether there
needs to be something i don't know
representative from the templeton group
should be coming down to pegasus
soon um he was due to come down and then
lockdown happened so that didn't happen
so and part of that is i know that he
actually wants to connect
with some of the residents so
i'm sort of just waiting to hear when
that will actually be
it's a community meeting
i'll come up with something under the
media we have no questions understanding
orders and we have
no urgent general business understanding
orders um
so just before i declare the meeting
closed i would like to thank you all
um you know the zoom meetings they were
we got better at them um and no they
were good there was a good way of
keeping in touch in a good way we did
actually keep some work
happening which was really good um and
now we get
to look forward to level one at midnight
tonight so
um onwards and upwards and hopefully we
never go backwards
so i would like to close this meeting
and thank you all
you